Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Converrete tutti con me
che l'ultimo anno e mezzo
ci ha messo tutti alla prova,
a causa del CoVid-19:
chiusi in casa, a volte
con un tempo contingentato per uscire;
nessuna possibilità di vedere
i vostri cari, o i vostri amici;
niente lavoro, niente scuola.
È stata dura,
e abbiamo avuto tutti
la sensazione di restare bloccati
per una vita intera,
non solo un anno e mezzo.
Siamo disperatamente in attesa
che tutto questo finisca.
Vogliamo disperatamente
una cura, un vaccino.
Vogliamo riavere la nostra libertà.
Vogliamo tornare a vivere
una vita normale.
Certo.
Ma se fosse questa,
la vostra vita normale?
E se doveste passarla in isolamento,
a proteggersi dagli agenti patogeni,
per tutta la vita,
dal giorno in cui siete nati?
E se doveste passare in lockdown
la vostra intera vita,
e non a casa vostra, seduti sul divano,
guardando la TV, cucinando la pizza,
ma all'interno di un ospedale
o in una stanza sterile -
o peggio ancora, dentro una bolla?
Può sembrare la trama
di un film di fantascienza,
ma non lo è.
Ci sono persone reali là fuori, bambini,
la cui vita è un lockdown
senza speranza e senza fine.
Questo è David Vetter, conosciuto anche
come il "Ragazzo nella bolla".
David è nato nel 1971 negli USA,
e ha vissuto tutta la sua
breve vita di 12 anni
all'interno di una bolla,
al Texas Children's Hospital.
David è nato, infatti,
con una rara malattia
chiamata Immunodeficienza
Combinata Severa, o SCID,
che ha reso il suo corpo incapace
di combattere qualsiasi tipo di infezione.
Pertanto, anche l'aria che respira
potrebbe essere letale per lui,
e anche il più semplice freddo
potrebbe ucciderlo,
per non parlare del CoVid-19.
Dalla nascita,
David non ha mai toccato
un altro essere umano
a mani nude,
compresa sua madre,
e non è mai uscito dalla bolla,
tranne che nelle ultime settimane
prima della sua morte, nel 1984.
Alzi la mano chi ha mai sentito parlare
di David o della SCID prima d'ora.
Bene, pochissimi di voi l'hanno fatto:
e questo perché la SCID
è una malattia rara.
Ma cosa signifca "rara"?
Lasciatemi dare qualche numero,
e qualche esempio.
Ogni anno, nascono
100 bambini con la SCID,
tutti nell'Unione Europea.
Non è molto, vero?
È abbastanza raro.
Il gruppo di immunodeficienze
primarie, come SCID,
comprende 300 malattie diverse,
il che porta il numero di bambini
nati con un compromesso
sistema immunitario
a 50.000, tutti in Europa.
È più alto, ma ancora raro.
Tuttavia, se si guarda l'intero gruppo
di malattie rare
che colpiscono l'essere umano,
le cose si fanno spaventose.
Ci sono infatti 7000
diverse malattie rare,
che colpiscono circa 30 milioni
di persone in Europa.
E 350.000.000 nel mondo.
E se pensiamo a tutti
i 350.000.000 cittadini Europei,
significa che quasi tutti
i cittadini europei
soffrirebbero di una malattia rara.
Potreste aver già sentito alcune
di queste malattie rare:
emofilia; talassemia;
fibrosi cistica; sclerosi multipla.
Il 50% dei pazienti con una malattia rara
sono bambini,
che costituiscono quasi 180.000.000
di bambini nel mondo
che soffrono di una malattia rara.
E ora vi racconterò
altri fatti sconvolgenti.
Le malattie rare sono gravi,
progressive e fatali,
come si è visto per la SCID.
Le malattie rare
sono responsabili, infatti,
del 35% dei decessi nei bambini
entro il primo anno di vita.
E cosa peggiore di tutte,
Il 95% di questi bambini,
di questi pazienti,
non hanno un trattamento.
A volte, nemmeno una diagnosi.
Un terzo dei pazienti rari
non riceve una diagnosi,
o aspettano in media quattro anni
per averne una precisa.
Come potete immaginare, questo è un peso
non solo per il paziente stesso;
ma anche per la famiglia,
i genitori, gli assistenti,
che spesso si sentono impotenti, isolati,
e le cui domande
sono spesso senza risposta.
Immaginate che a voi o ai vostri cari
sia stata diagnosticata una malattia
che è così rara,
che non c'è una causa conosciuta,
nessun dato online, nessun trattamento,
nessun supporto a cui rivolgersi.
Immaginate di sentirvi come se nessuno
potesse capire voi e la vostra malattia,
a volte nemmeno i vostri medici.
Si stima che una persona su 17
sarà impattata da una malattia rara,
ad un certo punto della sua vita.
Come paziente, come genitore,
come badante, amica di un paziente raro.
E solo per avere un'idea
di cosa sto parlando,
è come se sei persone
in questo pubblico oggi
avranno a che fare con una malattia rara
ad un certo punto della loro vita,
o 1.400 persone
solo nella città di Mirandola,
e 3,5 milioni circa in Italia.
E ancora, forse sarete
tra quelle persone, su 17,
che non saranno colpita
da una malattia rara, prima o poi,
direttamente o indirettamente;
e potreste avere la sensazione
che questo non vi riguardi.
Dovete sapere, tuttavia,
che dati gli effetti devastanti
che queste malattie hanno,
i pazienti rari hanno bisogno
di ricoveri molto frequenti:
per farsi trattare i sintomi;
per ricevere controlli sanitari ed esami.
E questo rappresenta un enorme peso
per il nostro sistema sanitario,
a cui tutti noi contribuiamo
pagando le nostre tasse ogni anno.
Spero, quindi, di aver chiarito
il mio punto di vista.
È che le malattie rare colpiscono
ogni singola persona in qualche modo.
Ho iniziato a studiare le malattie rare,
e i modi per trattarle,
approssimativamente all'età di 22 anni
quando ho avuto, per caso,
il mio tirocinio in laboratorio
in un laboratorio di terapia genica
all'Università di Modena e Reggio Emilia.
E ciò che mi ha sempre affascinato,
e al contempo più spaventato,
di queste malattie
è che hanno un'origine genetica,
vale a dire che sono causati
da un errore nel nostro DNA.
Ora, forse sapete tutti cos'è il DNA:
è il libro della vita,
è il libro di istruzioni del nostro corpo.
Questo libro contiene
sei miliardi di lettere,
e un singolo errore in una sola lettera
può portare ad una devastante,
grave, rara malattia genetica
come si è visto per la SCID.
Il fatto che risidea nel DNA
la causa principale di queste malattie
ha spinto gli scienziati a trovare modi
per trattare questo paziente
agendo direttamente sul DNA.
E questo è qualcosa su cui ho lavorato
negli ultimi 15 anni,
e sto parlando della terapia genica.
Quindi, con la terapia genica,
vogliamo correggere questo errore
nelle cellule staminali
del paziente stesso,
per mezzo dell'ingegneria genetica,
che avviene in laboratorio.
Nel caso della SCID, quindi,
o di malattie rare del sangue,
rimuoviamo un campione dal midollo osseo
o dal sangue del paziente,
e isoliamo le cellule staminali ematiche.
Le cellule staminali, quindi,
sono le "cellule madri",
l'elemento costitutivo di tutte le cellule
immunitarie e del sangue.
E perciò isoliamo queste cellule.
E poi procediamo
a cercare di correggere questo errore
introducendo una copia
corretta di questo DNA
che contiene l'errore,
e causa la malattia,
all'interno di queste cellule.
A quel punto, armati
di tutte le istruzioni vitali
e questo pezzo di DNA
che prima gli era sfuggito,
queste cellule possono essere
reinfuse nel paziente,
dove cresceranno
e daranno origine a un nuovo
e funzionante sistema immunitario,
nuove cellule e nuovo sangue.
Può sembrare un approccio futuristico,
ma la terapia genica è una realtà già ora.
Come vedete da questa mappa,
ci sono oltre 200
studi clinici di terapia genica
in corso in questo momento nel mondo.
E solo nel centro dove lavoro,
il Great Ormond Street
Children’s Hospital,
uno dei principali centri
per la terapia genica,
più di 60 pazienti
sono stati trattati con successo
attraverso la terapia genica.
La cosa interessante,
è che una delle prime malattie
ad essere trattata con la terapia genica
era un tipo di SCID,
la malattia di David Better.
E che quella terapia genica
fu in realtà uno dei primi
prodotti di terapia genica
a diventare una medicina,
che ora è disponibile attraverso
il nostro Sistema Sanitario Nazionale
per tutti i bambini affetti da SCID,
in Italia e nel mondo.
E come ulteriore prova
che benché possiate pensare
che non vi riguardi,
perché non siete affetti
da una malattia rara in alcun modo,
ora vi mostrerò come questo approccio
possa impattare molto anche su di voi.
Le terapie geniche, infatti,
nate inizialmente per trattare
malattie genetiche rare,
sono ora applicate con successo
per trattare alcuni tipi di cancro
sotto forma di terapia con cellule car-T.
Ed è ora una delle tecniche
più promettenti
per combattere il cancro,
una delle malattie meno rare.
Spero quindi di essere riuscita
a convincervi, oggi,
che la rarità è diffusa,
e che ci aspettano tempi entusiasmanti
per i pazienti rari, per il settore,
ma anche per tutti noi.
Tuttavia, come vi ho detto
all'inizio dell'intervento,
c'è ancora una quota enorme
di malattie rare
rimaste senza un trattamento,
e anche senza una diagnosi.
Cosa possiamo fare
per rendere questi trattamenti
disponibili a ogni paziente?
Come affrontare questa sfida?
Come possiamo migliorare la vita
di questi bambini, di questi pazienti
e anche delle loro famiglie?
Scienziati, medici,
farmacologi, accademici -
continueremo tutti a lottare e a lavorare
per trovare nuovi trattamenti
e nuovi modi di trattare
un numero crescente di queste malattie.
Niente di tutto questo accadrà, tuttavia,
se non scegliamo tutti di farlo accadere.
Come potete contribuire fin da oggi
e fare la differenza per i pazienti rari,
ma anche per la salute di tutti noi?
Prima di tutto, diventando
consapevoli della rarità,
comprendendo e riconoscendo
che c'è davvero una necessità medica
rimasta insoddisfatta.
Secondo, diffondendo la parola,
rendendo sempre più persone
consapevoli della rarità.
e dell'importanza di essere rari.
Terzo, credendo nela scienza
e sostenendola.
Se potete, donate e sostenete
enti e associazioni di beneficenza
che riuniscono la comunità dei rari
e che di solito fungono
da principali catalizzatori e finanziatori
della ricerca scientifica
per le malattie rare.
Se siete persona sane,
considerate di donare il vostro sangue,
o quello del cordone ombelicale
dei vostri neonati,
alla ricerca,
in modo che altri scienziati come me
possano sviluppare nuovi trattamenti.
Considerate la possibilità di iscrivervi
a un programma di trapianto
di midollo osseo:
potreste essere donatori compatibili
per uno dei pazienti come David,
per i quali un trapianto di midollo osseo
potrebbe salvare la vita.
Se non potete sostenere la scienza
matierialmente, difendetela almeno,
sostenete la ricerca
e il settore educativo di questo paese.
Destinate più risorse
alla ricerca accademica:
la maggior parte dei proof-of-principle
sulla terapia genica
provengono da lì.
Chiedete di assegnare più risorse
alle strutture e ai professionisti
dell'assistenza sanitaria.
Ultimo ma non meno importante,
niente di tutto questo accadrà
finché non cambieremo la nostra mentalità
e non diventiamo una comunità.
Dobbiamo convenire tutti
che ogni singola malattia,
ogni singolo paziente e la sua malattia
è altrettanto importante
quanto il benessere di tutti gli altri,
e che preoccuparsi dei rari
e preoccuparsi di pochi pazienti
a lungo termine beneficerà
l'intera comunità.
Dobbiamo tutti decidere
che ogni singolo bambino,
anche quello più raro,
vale la pena di lottare.
Dobbiamo decidere che tutti contano.
Grazie.
(Applausi)